is a screenshot so i haven't confirmed
this but apparently he referred to gay
men as ghouls like in an absolutely
derogatory way so if we're gonna if
we're gonna take him at his word and
that's how he describes people then i
don't trust him when he describes
himself that it's supposed to be you
know ingest or reappropriating the
language it shouldn't matter if you know
what to back to the point i kind of
derailed these activists you know what
they've done with crowder is they've
gone through two years worth of content
and snipped together all of these out of
context times he said certain things but
youtube realized when you watch the full
segment it was a passing moment and it
wasn't targeting carlos specifically
based on those traits it was just him
talking about something and then
mentioning the identity of maza by all
means
you can be mad at crowder for doing that
i i'm willing to listen to your opinion
but we go back and look at what carlos
mazza is saying throw milkshakes at
people and he actually and again i want
to clarify i didn't confirm this tweet
yet but it's going around now because
mazza has repeatedly referred to because
it seems like there's a lot of